[Music]
and this is book TV on c-span 2 and
today we are live from the Savannah Book
Festival in Georgia now in its 10th year
the festival is host to several authors
and events throughout downtown Savannah
and book TV is live all day inside one
of the larger venues Trinity United
Methodist Church from now until about
4:00 p.m. Eastern
you'll hear from several authors
including former CIA officer William
Doherty Fox Business News 'as Gerri
Willis journalist dance later and more
you'll also have the chance to speak
with several of the authors as well now
we're going to kick off our coverage in
Savannah with John Tammany he's the
author of a new book who needs the Fed
what Taylor Swift uber and robots
tell us about money credit and why we
should abolish America's central bank
this is live coverage from the Savannah
Book Festival in Georgia starting now
good morning book lovers hopefully
everything's working my name is Linda
Huntoon and I'm delighted to welcome you
to the 10th annual Savannah Book
Festival presented by Georgia Power and
the Sheehan Family Foundation we are
blessed to host such a sellout such
celebrated authors in the Trinity United
Methodist Church today which has been
made possible by the generosity of Kurt
and Libby Anderson we'd like to extend
special things to our literati members
and individual donors who have made and
continue to make Saturday's festival
free before I get started there's the
traditional caveats immediately
following this presentation John Tandy
will be signing festival purchase copies
of his book in Telfair Square his is
slightly different today because he has
a short interview with c-span
immediately follow so that gives you
time to get to the tent before him we
have a new policy this year if you're
planning for the next author
presentation to stay here please move
forward so that the venue empties and
the ushers can determine how many seats
they have for people coming in please
please please take this moment to turn
off your cell phones and we also ask
that you not use flash photography and
for the question and answer portion this
year we are passing microphone so
there's no lining up in the center aisle
or any of the some of the things we've
done in the years past there are lots of
people around with microphones and mr.
kami is happy to take questions
John Kemeny is with us today courtesy of
Paul and Letty McAdams and Barbara Paul
he is a senior fellow at Reason
Foundation a senior economic advisor to
toreador research and trading and an
editor of real clear market.com RCM mr.
Tammany frequently writes about the
securities market along with tax trade
and monetary policy issues that impact
those markets for a variety of
publications including The Wall Street
Journal investor's business daily
Financial Times National Review and
London's Daily Telegraph please give a
warm Savannah welcome to John Tammany
Linda thank you very much for the
gracious introduction and thank you to
all of you for being here today
it's a passion that book people like you
that make it possible for me to get to
do what I love and so I can't stress my
gratitude enough also want to thank the
Savannah Book Festival for including me
as I look out at the other authors and
the other books being featured this
weekend I can't believe I'm in such good
company these are authors who might read
for years I'm kind of clicking my heels
up here that I get to be part of this
and so I want to thank the excellent
festival Kim bak iya swing for all the
work she did to make it possible for me
to be here I'd like to add to that Letty
McAdams it's not in a literal sense but
I believe she moved mountains to get me
in the position to be here today and so
I'm forever in Letty's debt and also to
her husband Hall who's in the audience
today
they're quite simply would not be a book
called who needs the Fed if not for Hall
what Hall knows about banking and credit
could fill many many thick books and
over the last 13 years he's taught me
enormous amounts he's been so patient
and discussions in person by email over
the phone about these issues and if I
had not discussed all this with Hall and
learned so much from him there never
would have been a reason to write who
needs the Fed in the first place and so
big thanks to Hall before I get into the
book I'll talk a little bit about my
background I was actually born in
Charleston South Carolina so not too far
from here my dad was in the nuclear Navy
he served under the great Admiral Hyman
rickover once he got out of the Navy we
lived in Dallas in Atlanta and then we
moved to Boston for two years that he
could go to business school and then we
moved out to Los Angeles and I grew up
in Pasadena California it was probably
during grade school that I discovered
not knowing it at the time what I would
eventually be doing in terms of writing
about economics and economic policy
there were these little children's books
in grade school about presidents called
meet Thomas Jefferson meet Ben Franklin
meet George Washington and I would read
them over and over again and I would
kind of be off to the side in class
reading about these reading these books
and I went to my parents one night and I
said I'm worried that I'm in trouble at
school I'm not participating than the
other things and so my parents went to
the teacher and she and the teacher said
no we're thrilled but he's interested in
these books please have him continue and
so it was probably signaled something
ahead for college I went to the
University of Texas and majored in
political science but not for any good
reason it's just it seemed like the most
interesting major at the time I can't
say I learned a whole lot one way or the
other I think most kids in school that's
generally what they do their focuses are
elsewhere after college I worked in
sales for four years and then went to
Vanderbilt
Owen Graduate School of Management to
get my MBA
now while at Vanderbilt I decided to go
the normal route it was a booming bull
market in the late 90s so I thought okay
I'll get into this into equities just
like everyone else and I took a job at
Goldman Sachs and that's where what
began a future that's what that's where
my future career took shape while other
people were on the trading floor
passionate about equities I would look
around and watch CNBC on the different
screens and my focus was on the ekend
the Economist talking about the economy
that's what that's what really had my
interest in what intrigued me the most
is there was this constant stream of
commentary at the time in the late
nineties saying that if the economy grew
too much as in people prospered too much
if too many people were working and
creating companies that there was a
negative downside that it would cause
inflation and I thought wait a second I
grew up in the 1970s I know what
inflation is it's a devaluation of the
dollar it's when the Treasury dinks the
value of the dollar and I thought
inflation is something that occurs
exclusive of economic growth when
economies are growing investment surges
and so the prices of everything drop and
so I've looked throughout history I
remembered the first mobile phone and in
the night in the early 80s Motorola put
it out
brick sized a half-hour of battery life
if you want to make a call from Savannah
to Atlanta is gonna cost you a fortune
and roaming charges and I thought well
nowadays you can get mobile phones for a
fraction of the price and then I knew
from history that the first mainframe
computer was created by IBM in the 1960s
it cost over a million dollars even by
the late 90s you could get a pretty good
computer for a few thousand nowadays we
see we can get them for a few hundred
dollars but I thought that's another
example of the persistent drop in the
price of everything thanks to investment
everything I looked rejected the common
view of economics from economists that
somehow growth was a problem that the
senton that the Fed and central banks
had to plan it to make sure that we
didn't prosper enough and so I wasn't
allowed to do this goldman sachs was
full of immensely and talented people
and they were very specific that you did
your job that you didn't go outside what
you were doing but i secretly started
writing for clients commentary saying
that what you're hearing on CNBC what
you're reading in the newspapers is
belied by basic economic history and
common sense and so i I started thinking
this is what I really want to do and
then by 2001 the stock market started to
dive what people pejoratively referred
to as the internet bubble effectively
popped now what I would say about that
is I don't think there's such thing as a
bubble that run-up in Internet stocks
was a beautiful thing it was a sign of
economic progress as was the decline of
those internet companies it's when
economies are fit when there's lots of
failure in an economy that you know an
economy is progressing you need that
constant experimentation to get you into
a better place and so people looked at
that period as a negative but
I looked at it as a time in which the
the the world in the US economy were
utterly transformed by advances that we
could not live without today now the
downside to this big big drop in equity
prices particularly in the internet
economy was that suddenly goldman sachs
wasn't as interested in my services as
they had been a few years ago and i'll
say that was rather devastating at the
time you wonder you start to question
yourself you start to question what kind
of person you are can i ever succeed
again am i am i do for failure but in
fact it was the best thing that ever
happened to me because it i'd already
got caught the bug I thought I want to
be commenting on the economy about this
I'll stress upfront I'm not an economist
and I where that lack of a PhD with
pride I'm not a journalist either but I
thought I have got to write about this
it would pain me to not be in the field
of commentary in these subjects and so
the negative about goldman sachs
ultimately forced me to figure out what
i really wanted to do and ultimately i
moved to washington DC not as an
economist or as a writer about economics
but as a fundraiser for the cato
institute my plan was to pay the bills
working during the day meeting donors
that was how I was going to pay the
bills so that I can write at night and
on weekends and that's how I met Hall
McAdams and I met people like Hall who
utterly transformed how I viewed the
world and made it even made me even more
determined to become an economic
commentator and gradually I did I won't
go claim or Horatio Alger story or
anything like that but my initial online
columns that was the other beauty of the
internet boom has it made it possible
for someone like me to have a voice
whereas before I couldn't have had one
and so I began as a writer from
Washington DC no one no one wanted to
have an association with someone like me
but gradually I developed a reputation
and my reputation was one of basically
working against or contradicting the
conventional wisdom about economics
I felt that the economics profession had
lost its way that had become about
charts and formulas and percentages
rather than a beautiful story of human
action and I thought people don't
dislike economics they just dislike how
it's been explained to them and my
argument was that if people can see the
beautiful world around them if they
could understand sports movies
television famous people and businesses
they would understand all that they
would ever need to know about economics
and so that has been my style of writing
for all this time and so my first book
popular economics which all of you
should buy several copies have later
today was a book that explained economic
growth through movies and sports and
television it got rid of all the graphs
that it wrecked what is really
informative and essential and that's and
and and who needs the Fed which is the
book I'm talking about today is another
example I explained central banking and
credit and money through things that
people can understand and that's been my
goal throughout all this is that
economics is fun but people have taken
the fun out of it and it led to the book
who needs the Fed now about who needs
the Fed what I want to stress upfront is
please don't be fooled by the title and
recover this is a very optimistic book
this is a book that argues the Fed was
never nearly as powerful or or
influential as is commonly assumed and
even better that market forces are
rapidly rendering the Fed irrelevant
right before our eyes what can't be
stressed about enough about the Fed is
that it doesn't have any resources it
can't increase credit it cannot shrink
credit the Fed can only miss allocate
the credit that we've already created in
the real economy the Fed is large not
because of the talented people there it
doesn't it's not active in the markets
because the people there have a specific
skill that the rest of the that central
bankers around the world don't have
let's remember there are central banks
in Nigeria Cayman Islands Barbados
tomah's central banks are everywhere we
have a large one simply because the
American people are the most
economically productive people on earth
the feds swagger is not its own and
that's the broad point of my book that
when we talk about the Fed we're
misunderstanding it doesn't have the
credit it can't increase it the Fed can
only miss allocate the resources we've
already created and the argument I make
in the book is that we vastly overstate
just how much the Fed miss allocates
it's just not that important but I'm a
big believer in market forces and market
signals I think that they're full of
information and in the same way I think
the electorate is full of information
there is lots of skepticism right now in
the world about our central bank and I
think there's some skepticism based on
one on a misperception and two based on
a very real understanding that the world
the Fed lives in is not defined by
reality
now the misperception is rooted in the
idea popularized by economists
politicians and pundits that money and
credit are one in the same but in fact
money and credit couldn't be more
different if they were the same Haiti
and Honduras would have every bit as
much credit flowing through their
economies as we do in the United States
I would add that that would mean that
counterfeiting would not only be legal
but it'd be broadly encouraged in fact
credit is real economic resources to
paraphrase Ludwig von Mises when you
borrow dollars you're not borrowing
dollars you're borrowing access to
computers trucks tractors desks chairs
buildings most of all labor
we are the credit in the economy we are
the producers of the resources that when
people seek to borrow dollars they're
trying to attain the Fed has no private
stash of resources over here that it can
release into the economy we are the
creators of it now the frustration with
the Fed is somewhat separate people read
in the meat they watch Pete the pundits
on TV they read in newspapers will the
Fed ease will the Fed tight
and credit will the Fed keep money easy
at 0% and I think the electorate
properly looks at that and says
something's wrong with this picture that
doesn't reflect the reality that we know
Apple computers the most valuable
company in the world yet even it pays 3
percent to borrow anyone who's ever
started a small business or own a small
business knows that to attain credit it
cost quite a bit more than threat than
0% it's much higher than 3% higher and
higher all the time and that's the broad
point of the first part of my book is
that while the feds over here de creme
easy access to credit and easy money and
it's infinite on wisdom in the real
economy we act as though the Fed doesn't
exist and that's a very positive
statement about where we are thinking
about Hollywood Brian Grazer is easily
the most talented movie producer in the
history of the industry we're talking
about splash Parenthood a beautiful mind
Apollo 13 talking about television shows
like Empire 24 and Arrested Development
but his Grey's are freely acknowledges
his attempts to attain credit to fund
his movie and TV ideas fail 90% of the
time for this person with a near-perfect
track record
Hollywood as he puts it is the land of
know what about Silicon Valley it's
commonly assumed that if you've got a
start-up idea out in the valley that
money sources will beat a path to your
door trying to invest with you but as
evidenced by all the billionaire venture
capitalist out the Silicon Valley we
know that credits incredibly expensive
out there if you want to fund your
startup idea you'll first give up a big
portion of your business to a venture
capitalist and then you'll give up even
more of it in the form of stock options
to lure potential employees what about
Investment Banking one of the things
that offends me most in modern times is
how media members have made Wall Street
a pejorative and it created the
perception that investment bankers are
somehow bad people I can't think of a
more important profession
an investment banking and one of the
reasons they're paid so well
has to do with the basic truth that in
the real economy the price of credits
very expensive it's one thing to come up
with an idea for it for a business or
come up with an idea to expand your
business but it's quite another thing to
attain the resources the credit
necessary to build on your vision and so
investment bankers are paid very well
properly so because they can do for
businesses what businesses can't do for
themselves many of you remember the name
Michael Milken the media in a similar
way demonized him he spent time in
prison for charges that had never been
prosecuted on anyone before I would
argue that michael milken's one of the
greatest capitalists who ever lived and
his insight back in the 1960s and 70s
was that unless you are the bluest of
blue chip businesses you were largely
shut out of the credit markets the
traditional banks did not regard you as
a reasonable credit risk and some
milken's genius hid the source of his
fortune was the high-yield bond it was
his way of finding more expensive credit
for really promising businesses Time
Warner CNN Golden Nugget hotels the list
is long of the great businesses that he
attained credit for and the broad point
is Milken's fortune was a function of
the fact that while the feds often
never-never-land to create easy credit
he found it for very difficult credit
sources unless you're a blue chip it's
very hard to attain credit in the real
economy all of which brings us to our
45th president Donald Trump I like to
sell books and so I like to have stories
about people who are famous I feel like
that will drive more people to buy it as
all of you should and so thinking about
Donald Trump and let me stress that this
is not a political statement many of you
remember that he reached his height as a
real estate mogul back in the 1980s
that's when he was viewed as the
developer who could do no wrong the man
who had the vision for what the future
of tall buildings would be now what's
interesting about Trump is that as early
as nineteen
he was already viewed as a very major
credit risk by US banks in 1990 I tell
the story in the book he flew out to Los
Angeles to visit with security Pacific
Bank which at the time was the fifth
largest US bank he wanted to borrow 50
million dollars in order to fund the
revitalization of the Ambassador Hotel
now as you can imagine from modern times
Trump arrived at this meeting full of
confidence and swagger about his amazing
balance sheet of assets full of some of
the best properties on earth and there
were that were easily highly liquid
he was the best lending option you had
out there why wouldn't she probably
should give me a hundred million dollars
well the bankers had an entirely
different view of his assets they didn't
trust them they looked at them as highly
illiquid that if he ran into difficulty
paying off his debt these wouldn't
necessarily be easily sold and so they
refused his request for a 50 million
dollar loan and they ultimately loaned
him 10 million they wanted to be
associated with his celebrity and they
ultimately lived to regret that decision
two years later they wrote down the loan
in total he didn't pay a dime back and
it's been well known ever since the
early 90s that US banks generally have
not touched Donald Trump he was viewed
as toxic he had a very bad credit
reputation when the US banks let me
stress that's not a political statement
but it is a statement about credit while
the Fed is once again over here de creme
zero rates of interest in the real
economy interest rates flowed up and
down as though the Fed doesn't exist
and again that's a hugely positive
statement about the US and global
economy that I would add if the Fed were
a fraction of as powerful as is commonly
assumed we wouldn't be the richest
nation on earth it's the fact that the
feds just not that consequential there's
a signal that we're an incredibly rich
nation it just doesn't influence the
flow of credit nearly as much as people
think only among academics and
economists
untouched by reality and untouched by
the real world is there such thing as
easy credit in the real economy its
price is set by market forces and that's
a very positive thing and so the
question in the book becomes do we need
a Federal Reserve do we need a central
bank as you can probably guess my take
is that we don't need one my argument is
that if the Fed were shut down tomorrow
few would notice the Fed began a hundred
years ago and a little over 100 years
ago in 1913 as a lender of last resort
to solvent banks if you were a very
well-run bank with excellent assets on
your books and you ran into a near-term
cash crunch the Fed existed as a source
of a loan just to tide you over until
some of the cash came back in but as
we've seen over the last 100 plus years
it's unheard of for a solvent bank to go
to the Fed for a loan to do so is an
admission of bankruptcy and that's the
case because there are myriad non fed
sources of credit always willing to lend
to a well-run bank and so what this is
meant for the banking system overall is
that the Fed has existed to weaken it
because the Fed has become a lender of
last resort to insolvent banks that did
not rate alone in the real economy
imagine that in Silicon Valley if there
is always a central authority that could
bail out your weakest companies that
means that Webvan Fred's Friendster the
globe calm and eToys would still exist
Silicon Valley would be a very rundown
kind of impoverished place its wealth as
a function of the fact that it's bad
businesses regularly die the Fed has
weakened the banking system by virtue of
it propping up over the years the
weakest at the expense of the most
successful banks the Fed is also a bank
regulator now my argument and this will
offend a few is that what a what a
laughable presumption if you're working
at the Fed that's usually a signal you
couldn't get a job at a bank in the
first place
and so you're asking those of lesser
talent to police those who have much
more talent but I would add that with
regulators and regulations we're asking
the impossible of them we're asking
something of them that even the smartest
bankers in the world could not do we're
asking them to see into the future to
detect detect trouble spots within banks
well before problems arise well if they
could do that
they'd be earning billions in the
private sector they would quite
literally be the richest investors in
the world because even the smartest
investors in the world fully admit that
majority of the time they relate to a
problem so the regulation we're asking
the impossible meaning it's very
expensive but it achieves less than
nothing just weakens the banking system
even more and of course the Fed famously
targets the rate at which banks lend to
one another overnight the Fed Funds rate
but an interest rates a price like any
other you don't need the Federal Reserve
for that banks could easily set that
price and do on their own the Fed
targets it doesn't set anything and so
again my argument is we should end what
serves no useful purpose if we ended the
Fed few would notice but I fully accept
that my view is a bit on the outside if
you talk to most economists they would
say oh my we could think the economy
quite simply couldn't function without a
central bank what are you talking about
we would be in a non-stop depression
mode if not for the Federal Reserve
don't you know and I point out that john
d rockefeller became the richest man in
the world before the Fed but they that
they it's constantly rejected the very
idea that I would say we don't need a
central bank but and so that the
arguments are many the Keynesian school
of economics makes the broad point about
the Fed that we need it to increase
credit in the economy during
recessionary periods to basically prop
up an economy that's weakening her
that's in freefall now this theory fails
in two very important ways for one it
can't be forgotten the recessions are
incredibly healthy as agonizing as they
are as dispiriting as much as they kill
or morale in the near term recessions
are the amazingly bullish signal of the
massive economic boom on the way simply
be as recession signal and economy
cleansing itself of all the misuses of
labor of all the bad habits all the bad
investments and all the lousy companies
that we're holding the economy down in
the first place
and so in recessions take hold that's
the exact time when you want government
to do less than nothing simply because
recessions if left alone signal the boom
on the way and so you don't want a
central bank acting in trying to
allocate credit that means that the
private sector has less credit to
allocate and it means bad companies are
being propped up at the expense of what
would be much greater future growth the
other problem with the Keynesian theory
gets back to something more basic the
Fed has no credit to increase again it
doesn't have some private stash of
resources around the country that it can
release into the economy the Fed can
only increase credit insofar as market
disciplined actors in the real economy
have less to increase and so as a rule
when the Fed or any central bank acts
aggressively to fight a recession in
fact what it's doing is fighting the
recovery simply because it's
instantaneously miss allocating
resources that would otherwise be pushed
to a higher use usually miss allocating
to what's already failed the economy's
broad detriment now the monetarist
school of economics has a very different
view and in in fairness to its somewhat
of a more limited view of what the
Federal Reserve should do monetarists
argue that the Fed should control the
money supply that it should oversee a
set increase in the supply of dollars in
a circulation on an annual basis the
late Milton Friedman the Nobel Prize
laureate and free-market ear
extraordinaire is as most associated
with this view my comment in the book is
that this is an example of Milton
Friedman explicitly promoting central
planning and the reason for that is
basic money supplies never a problem
where there's productivity to paraphrase
ludwig von mises once again
no nation or individual need ever worry
about having too much too little money
where there's enormous amounts of
productivity money and credit are
everywhere where there's very little
productivity money and credit are always
in everywhere scarce to get into
specifics Beverly Hills never has a
money supply problem Greenwich
Connecticut never has a money supply
problem the Fed couldn't keep money
supply and credit off of the island of
Manhattan on its very best day there are
too many productive people there such
that they're a magnet for credit and the
money that she used to attain that
credit but let's let's imagine a city
that's suffering economic problems right
now a poorer city city like Baltimore in
Maryland let's imagine if the Fed
because the Fed believes it can
stimulate economic growth with its
monetary policies let's imagine that the
Fed decides to stimulate Baltimore and
it proceeds to buy up Treasuries from
Baltimore banks to increase loanable
funds and the banks there such a
scenario would fail between breakfast
and lunch and it would simply because
banks can't long stay in business
lending to individuals and businesses
who lack the means to pay the money's
borrowed back and so any increase in the
supply of dollar credit in Baltimore
would instantaneously leave Baltimore
from those banks outside the city and
probably outside of the state of
Maryland itself now in modern times
economists always look for new ways to
aggrandize themselves and add to their
importance they're always looking to
solutions when an economy is just
individuals that if left alone would do
just fine and so the latest in the past
years economists have talked about
helicopter drops of money now by that
they're not talking literally about the
Fed dropping helicopter money into
cities but their ideas let's just
produce money on mass and people consume
that will lead to economic growth but
let's let's let the Fed does have an Air
Force so let's imagine a drop of
billions of dollars into the city of
Baltimore and let's imagine something
even more realistic that the citizens of
the city
he would pick these billions of dollars
up and spend them right there but let's
assume that such a scenario would fail
just as much as the increase in the
supply of money in banks and it would
simply because even if they spent every
dollar in Baltimore no business is going
to expand based on a helicopter drop so
they'd Bank the windfall and the money
would once again be rapidly lent out
well outside of Baltimore now people
actual economists say well John you're
not an economist you'd understand
central bank's focus on countries and
okay so let's focus on a country several
years ago when Greece ran into economic
trouble monetarists argued that the
answer is for the european central bank
to increase the supply of euros and
greek banks okay but the same scenario
applies economic enact activity in
Greece did not rate increased money and
credits so any increase in the supply of
euros and Greek banks would boomerang
back to Germany and other more
economically productive locales almost
instantaneously now let's reverse the
scenario now and think about Silicon
Valley a place that's known for enormous
wealth and productivity in this instance
the Fed believes right up to the top
that economic growth causes inflation
you've heard me say that already but
it's something that I'm passionate about
the very people who are oddly charged
with planning our economy which they
can't do but the people charged that
actually believe that more that
prosperity has a downside and so the Fed
is forever believed that it must neuter
economic growth essentially put people
out of work to slow down the economic
growth that would otherwise cause
inflation so let's imagine the Fed seen
Silicon Valley says okay we're gonna
start selling bonds to Silicon Valley
banks to decrease the supply of money
there well such a scenario would fail
between lunch and dinner almost
instantaneously and it would because we
reside in a global economy
there are savers and investors around
the world desperate for exposure to the
most economically productive people on
earth so if the Fed shrinks the supply
of dollars in those banks who would be
made up and contained
by savers around the world the broad
point here is that the Fed quite simply
cannot increase money and credit input
in locales where there's not a lot of
productivity and that are struggling
economically economically as a result
much the same in productive locales
there's no need for the Fed money and
credit sources around the world are
fighting to have exposure to it the Fed
quite simply cannot do what its critics
and its supporters say it can do all
which brings us to the Austrian school
now my book isn't is an explicit tribute
to Ludwig von Mises classic book the
theory of money and credit but despite
that in the book I'm very critical of
what I term neo or modern Austrians
modern many modern Austrians have made
the argument that the major u.s.
economic booms of the of the 20th
century 1920s 1980s 1990s were a
creation of an easy central bank
creating excess credit and basically
putting the economy on a sugar high they
also argue that China's modern rise was
a function of an easy central bank in
China once again printing with abandon
and creating easy credit my point in the
book is that this is an example of the
Austrians embracing the very
Keynesianism that they despised that
they run away from because Austrians
correctly make the point when they
talked to Keynes Ian's Keynes Ian's will
say the one another way to stimulate the
economy is for governments to spend with
abandon and Austrians make the correct
point that no governments can only spend
insofar as they extract a real resources
from the private sector first the
negatives for the economy are
instantaneous when governments presume
to spend because politicians this is
true of Republicans or Democrats can
allocate precious resources and
discipline fashion as the spending is
immediate in terms of its negativity for
growth well my response is how are
central bank's different why is it that
governments can't allocate and
politicians can't allocate resources why
do we believe that central
can when central banks seek to influence
credit markets and seek to direct credit
to specific locales or countries they
instantaneously injured the economy
because once again resources are being
allocated in non-economic fashion
there's not even a near-term boom from
central bank masa nations as a rule when
they act there's less resources for the
private sector to allocate in terms of
excess credit there's quite simply no
such thing once again when you borrow
money you're borrowing resources trucks
tractors computers the Fed cannot
multiply them it can't release them in
excess that's what we create Nick in the
real economy but getting back to the my
examples from Hollywood Silicon Valley
investment banking Donald Trump what we
find and this is a happy story is that
the feds just not that influential
despite all of its efforts to make
credit easy in the real economy the
price of credit floats at rates that
reflect reality and again that's a very
positive statement the feds just not
that important it staggers me that we
give it so much attention its influence
over the economy is just not that great
now the response I get to all this is
one is something about quantitative
easing what I usually get from people is
they'll say okay interesting theory you
have here but what about quantitative
easing from 20 2008 until 2014 the Fed
oversaw a major program that not only
stimulated the US economy but also
stimulated a major stock market boom
they say what's your answer to that and
I say my answer is you need to check
your assumptions because what you
believe is belied by basic common sense
now about quantitative easing let's talk
about what that is economically first
that was the Fed borrowing four trillion
from banks and proceeding to buy up US
Treasuries with an eye on influencing
long rates of interest downward and also
buying up mortgages to stimulate the
housing market so let's get one thing
out of the way right here quantitative
easing had nothing to do with economic
as a rule it weakened the economy and
that's the case because governments once
again can't spend us to prosperity they
can only miss allocate the wealth we've
already created as for housing it is not
a driver of economic activity when you
buy a house your purchase of a house
doesn't make you more productive it
doesn't open up foreign markets for you
it doesn't lead to cancer here's the the
elongate life it doesn't lead to
software innovations that make us more
productive it doesn't expand time
housing is consumption that reduces the
amount of capital available for
entrepreneurs and businesses to expand
and securely on its face was an economic
depressant not a driver of growth at
which point to believe that it
stimulated a stock market boom you have
to believe that the deepest markets in
the world that is the US markets
populated by the most sophisticated
investors in the world were tricked by
something so plainly and nimma chol to
economic growth I think the very idea
offends what we're all about the idea
that these guys could trick the smartest
markets in the world let's be serious
but I get all the responses and I one of
my favorite ones came from an economist
in Austin Texas he said oh no no no
Johnny you're not an economist see you
don't understand the Fed and conducting
quantitative easing signaled to
investors that we've got your back that
if you buy equities will protect you
we'll keep those markets propped up and
that's what caused the stock market
rally and he added I learned this from a
Nobel laureate economist and I said okay
Lacey great point but if what you say is
true can you explain to me Japan because
see Japan's central bank has voiced as
no lever no less than eleven qyz on its
economy since the early 1990s with no
corresponding stock market rally our
Janet Yellen and Ben Bernanke utterly
competent in ways that you know Japan's
central bankers don't have a clue and
the response you get
from that as well but Jhansi you don't
understand what the Fed did was push
down interest for the the QE pushed down
interest rates across in the in the u.s.
such that people had to get into
equities because that was the only place
where they could get any kind of
reasonable yield I say okay that's again
a really interesting theory except I
hope you'll explain to me Japan once
again because it's had lower interest
rates across the yield curve for decades
but its stock market is still half of
what it was in 1989 and I say also why
didn't the stocks rally in 2000 2001
when the Fed was aggressively pushing
down rates yet stocks went into freefall
did it not work there was Alan Greenspan
maybe not as as skillful as a Ben
Bernanke and they they kind of dissemble
and they say well yeah but see Johnny
you don't understand see what actually
happened is the Fed in conducting
quantitative easing drove down yields on
bonds so much that equities became the
only game in town people had rotated out
of these low yielding bonds into
equities and I say ok again a very
interesting theory but if what you say
is true there would have been a massive
correction in bonds from 2008 to 2014
that would have reflected this rotation
out of low yielding bonds and equities
but that never occurred the only major
correction and bonds occurred after
Donald Trump was elected I don't see
your argument please explain they say
well yeah but see you're not getting it
the Fed created four trillion dollars
that had to find its way into the stock
market and it had nowhere to go but this
stock market and I say well didn't
really create four trillion but if you
want to believe that that's fine but for
4 trillion to enter the stock market by
definition for trillion must exit in
this netherworld inhabited by economists
and academics there are only buyers but
in the real world for a buyer to express
optimism a seller must be able to
express an equal amount of pessimism for
a QE excited optimist to express that
view in the stock market as a rule a QE
skeptic must get to express an equal
amount of pessimism in markets they are
always in everywhere
related buyers and buy buyers and
sellers for for a bull to be optimistic
in the market a bear must express an
equal amount of pessimism these things
equal each other out at which point we
get to the basic truth about markets
themselves they quite simply do not
price in the present they always price
in the future well the feds official
program of quantitative easing ended in
2014 but a telegraphed its end as early
as 2011 so if in fact QE had been the
driver of this stock market rally logic
dictates that stocks would have
corrected and corrected for good long
before 2014 to reflect the feds eventual
end of the program but in fact stocks
have continued to reach new highs
there's quite simply no evidence despite
what we're told that the Fed created a
stock market rally but there are lots of
people who believe that most economists
will tell you that most of cons will say
he's not what he doesn't know what he's
talking about you can read Morgan
Stanley's Russia or Sharma he regularly
puts op-eds into the Wall Street Journal
saying oh no we on Wall Street realized
this stock market boom was just a
creation of the Fed and so you're
welcome to that point of view I fully
agree that I am on the outside on this
making a different argument but if you
believe that if you believe the Fed
despite all evidence and logic was the
source of a major stock market rally
over these last several years what you
must then acknowledge is that in
creating the stock market rally the Fed
robbed us of one that would have been
quite a bit greater and the reason for
that is fairly basic recessions are once
again healthy they signal an economy
cleansing itself of what doesn't work
economy's gained strength from their
weakness in much the same way stock
markets gain strength from their
weakness it's when a markets correct
that precious resources are redirected
away from poorly run businesses
better run one so if in fact the Fed was
the source of the rally
it kept precious resources and lousy
marginal companies that they expensive
much better ones thus robbing us of a
much healthier and higher stock market
and so again that's the purpose of my
book my book is to unmask the Fed is not
that important as not that consequential
I say and what is an offense to common
sense just because we don't need the Fed
but I have no illusions the Fed will
never be ended no politician no
president no Congress will ever end the
Fed rest assured that's the bad news for
those who want and over with here's the
good news market forces are ending the
Fed for us the channel through which the
Fed presumes to influence the economy is
the banking system the US banking system
presently represents 15% of total credit
in the economy that numbers and freefall
and it is because banks are being
suffocated before our eyes by the same
federal government to save them and that
number is going to drop with the decline
of banks so declines the feds power
market forces are ending the Fed for us
we don't need Congress to do it and I'll
leave it there thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we don't have a lot of time for
questions and for that I apologize I got
wrapped up in what he was saying
please join me again in thanking John
upon exiting this venue our wonderful
volunteers will enthusiastically accept
your donation to the Savannah Book
Festival it is because of your
generosity that we're able to keep it
free so thank you so much for coming and
forgive me for no questions
[Applause]
[Music]
you're all convinced